can tell this hair looks cool or just
gross guys today is a very special
episode of its grace
last year I was approached by the
company st. Ives which is a lotion face
washing such excetera type of company
and I know them very well because I used
their apricot scrub on the face all the
time it's been in favourites videos
before but they came to me and they were
like we have this new product that we
want to work with you on promoting it in
some way and I was like send me the
product and they send me the product and
this is what it is and it's a lotion
that you spray on your person ah yeah it
smells like coconut and vanilla and
delicious so they allowed me to create
for them the most ridiculous lotion
commercial of all time because lotion
commercials are inherently very kind of
ridiculous and so they let me be stupid
in the commercial the best way possible
so that commercial that we created last
year that it's finally finished lives
over on the st. Ives website you can go
watch that commercial in its entirety or
spot is it a commercial I don't even
know it's just basically a hilarious
look at lotion and so this video today
is my behind-the-scenes of creating that
spot for st. Ives and some bloopers that
you didn't get to see in the spot itself
so I hope you guys enjoy it I had a
really great time making it
that's not p.m. that's a.m. good morning
guys
I'm getting ready for the state I've
shoot that's happening in my home give
me a lot of people invading it and about
an hour and some minutes now is when I
clean feel great you look great you look
great you look great you look great you
look great you look great you look great
you look great
you look great crazy Latrice is great
everyone looks great you look great
these look great
juice boxes for adults we're getting
ready to shoot here's me movie magic day
one of the shooters wrapped you have
another day I can you don't know you
can't see that but you are covered in
lotion I had to spray lotion so much and
it got everywhere day one is wrapped and
we will be shooting day two on Monday
and the I hear rumors that I'm gonna put
in a harness he'll you fetish weirdos
it's day two of the st. Ives shoot
okay the fun thing about Los Angeles is
that you can be completely stopped on a
highway oh now we're going yeah
ten feet closer to the shoot cool
wardrobe and they are just a bunch of
dudes hanging out this is how we rough
up shoes make them look less new nature
nature nature nature nature nature
nature this is complicated business the
shirt that I'm wearing right now
actually has tearaway sleeves courtesy
of Janette and I get to rip my sleeves
off hot style I'm so excited
and there's a lot of this checking your
phone while you're working a beautiful
lens flare on you checking your phone oh
yeah just a bunch of adult men
discussing the logistics of a flower if
they say about large flowers why are
they so big oh we're doing stunts can
you see this I'm wearing a harness and
men's boxer briefs today's a day
classic Monday say Monday know what's -
hey what's the craziest stunt they've
done I crashed days San Francisco city
bus into a San Francisco ambulance Wow
it wasn't even for a job well I left a
rap on the st. Ives shoot the video is
gonna be really funny I hope you guys
like it cause it's just so over the top
ridiculous and I got to wear harness and
levitate and I walk down this creepy
creepy road to my car what a life if I
keep doing this maybe people will think
I'm too crazy to actually lug me yeah
that's the ticket sports he loves me he
loves me not
it's complicated far